for
to
f
member states at the same time the
Republic of Serbia is a leading trade
partner for the European Union in the
western Balkans the Republic of Serbia
has 50% share in the export of
overall uh WB export to the EU so Serbia
alone 50% all the others 50% so during
the past 10 years we have achieved the
biggest growth rate of the EU
export 4.4% speaking about exchange of
goods in period between January and
August
2023 overall and total value for the
first eight months is almost 26 billion
Euro which is
25.82 billion e the value of uh export
is even higher by
10.06 billion so 5.2% bigger while
import is 2.4% a bit smaller the
coverage of import by export is almost
unbelievable for Serbia
87.7% and the deficit is lower
by 929.com
both German French Italian investors who
are exporting their products from here
to the EU Market first of all to all
those countries they come from and even
broader to that to the European soil
speaking about
fdis in the past 12
years from the EU totally
2.31 billion euro is in all overall FDI
which is
58.4% in first two quarters of 20
23 FD from the EU are
51.1% of overall inflow of fdis in
2023 those are the data which are of
huge importance for us and I want to
tell you that total value of
our trade exchange with European Union
is
58.5% with all others we have who have
41.5% counting on the significant
representation of the region here I said
this because we have so many projects
together with the EU together today we
heard the encouraging words from
president
F uh speaking about her growth plan
where we expect significant support
significant financial support if we
stick to our obligations of course we're
one3
should be for the budget and the
rest is already planned according to the
standard programs and plans which are
prepared in
advance and this is not small money for
us establishing it forming the uh unique
regional market and then participation
in the unique European market which is a
priority for Serbia and we see good
benefits in all this for all our
citizens additionally
I must underline a fact that today we
work on many important projects with the
EU particular when it comes to the field
of infrastructure when it comes to
energy infrastructure I want to thank
Ula ferline because only this year we
got 168 million euro from the EU people
in
Serbia should know this it's good that
they know it because those are grants
that the Republic of Serbia received
what's also important that uh speaking
about the most important projects when
it comes to the transport and energy
infrastructure are still carried out
with the EU so we expect in 15 days to
um have
finished and including all the licenses
and permits by the end of November inter
connector between Bulgaria and Serbia
for which we received huge grants and
supports and funds from the EU which is
very important for the diversification
of the gas supply which we have
discussed numerous occasions with Madam
ferline additionally of utmost important
for us is
maybe maybe of substantial or maybe the
crucial importance if I put it in simple
Serbian highspeed railroad between
Belgrade and nishe uh in seven days we
start with the section between Nish and
Di dimitr and with the EU Nish bre
towards leov once we finish Belgrade
Niche we'll have connected everything
from Belgrade to Istanbul because the
bulgarians are going to start
constructing between sopia and Istanbul
so from
Niche maximum four to five hours to
Istanbul 7 hours from Belgrade to
Istanbul by train those are incredible
things once it's finished of course we
would not be able to finance it all by
ourselves if it if there weren't for the
EU Who provided us with a huge help both
in Grants but also in cheap
loans
uh it used to be called a free lunch
when you get it um with such low
interest rates from ebrd and European
Investment Bank so today there are no
cheap there's no cheap money anymore so
we are very grateful once we can get
such a cheap money from the EU of course
I don't want to speak much longer here I
could also read through the project or
and I both concluded that we could spend
20 minutes speaking about projects only
we spoke also about political situation
we spoke about the situation in the
region and I said what is it that we
think and I'm going to repeat it
everything I said in Brussels after the
last meeting with the the European
leaders Mr Michelle B luk and with
leaders of the three biggest
countries Mr Schultz maon and Georgia
Mone Serbia is committed to preservation
of peace and stability Serbia knows its
obligations in accordance with the
agreed Serbia will meet on its
obligations it is clear for Serbia what
it cannot do against its own
constitutions and we told and uh this to
all our partners not only once but on
several occasions this is the position
of Serbia that will remain as it is let
me repeat once again what is it that the
Republic of Serbia accepted and what we
discussed and made conclusions about in
The National assembly of the Republic of
Serbia in accordance with that we're
going to act responsibly in meeting our
own obligations expecting that some
others also meet their obligations they
were supposed to meet more than 11 years
ago or almost 11 years ago
anyway dear Ursula once again thank you
once again for your
visit to us it's always a big and
important news to have you in Serbia we
hope to see you here more often and I
particularly want to to thank you for
not coming to Belgrade last two times
but you visited the south of Serbia
didn't come to Belgrade on that occasion
because we want especially to uh point
the attention to that part of our
country which with your help and your
support must develop faster and so thank
you even and even though I know it's
always easier for you to travel only to
Belgrade thank you for having
understanding and for being one of among
few European leaders who agreed to visit
other parts of our country on two
occasions and I hope that I will have
the opportunity to host you maybe next
time in the western part of Serbia thank
you once again thank you Mr President I
kindly ask president of the European
commission Madame M ferine to take the
floor
what I want is to look forward on our
growth plan the new growth plan to
getting our economies closer to each
other this new growth plan for the
Western Balkans has four steps the first
step is we openen our single Market to
the companies and businesses of the
western Balan countries
the second element is in return the
Western Balkan countries open their
market economies to their neighbors so
really create the common regional market
of the western Balan the potential of
this common regional market of the
western Balkan is enormous if it would
be uh comp completed we could increase
the GDP of the western Balkan economies
by
10% the third element is if we open the
single Market of the European Union and
we have a common regional market of the
western Balkan we need a Level Playing
Field and for that reforms have to be
done and here comes the fourth element
if you do the reforms we come with
investment for Serbia for example um
this would be improving the business
environment making the energy sector
ready we're working on it on the green
transition uh the focus on Education and
Training people for the jobs of tomorrow
just to name a few topics where there
can be reforms and investment together
um in addition judicial Independence
reforms are essential on media Freedom
you just finalized important
reforms um congratulations on that one
now we need you need to implement it and
keep on working in this sector um so
this is the package of re forms plus uh
the
investment now this new growth
plan um includes 6 billion EUR for
investment in the western Balkan
economies um we made a very good
experience in the European Union if we
combined investment and reforms we did
that after the pandemic with our um
investment plan Next Generation EU and
it worked very well to have the
investment
accompanied by reforms so if it works
for the member states I think it would
will also work for us together this
growth plan will boost your economy it
will most importantly create good jobs
and of course it will also support you
on your path to uh accession I believe
this is the right offer at the right
time my last message is we need
normalization between Serbia and Kosovo
the violent attack of the 24th of
September in North Kosovo um is
completely
unacceptable the perpetrators must be
held accountable and brought to Justice
um this is absolutely crucial um for
both to engage and to go the path of
normalization in this respect it is
important that Serbia should endorse the
statute of the association Community
Kosovo has to implement this
statute and in addition it is essential
that Serbia Begins the implementation of
the existing agreements and does not
lose time on
this going forward with that the right
place to discuss all these issues is the
EU facilitated dialogue this is the only
way forward it is a good way to access
the growth plan but more importantly it
is the best way to towards a future in
which Serbia is part of the European
Union thank
you newb for the president of the
European commission today you did not
mention this but you said this yesterday
in Pristina that Serbia among other
things should deliver the facto
recognition of Kosovo Independence now I
want to know how can you ask that when
five EU member states do not recognize
Kosovo both de facto nor the Europe
finally did those countries agree to a
request like that the second question is
for the president of Serbia you were
given the draft statute for the
community of Serbia municipalities when
the big five visited Belgrade you said
that those who brought it are knocking
uh the an Open Door does it mean that
that draft is acceptable and also do you
have some details what the factor
recognition means thank you
let me be totally
open to us recognition of kosovo's
Independence in that's not a question
and I said that on numerous of occasions
I'm not ashamed and proud to say that
also in front of the president of the
European commission we know what our
obligations are our dialog obligations
and we are ready to deliver on those
obligations but I must point to one
thing and this is not uh president of
European commission's fault nor
anybody's
fault from Europe maybe somebody's fa
but definitely not uroff underlines
that's a fact that for 11 years before
all the agreements when only one
obligation Pristina signed which is to
establish the community of ser majority
municipalities and it didn't do that we
had all the papers and principles that
were adopted that should be respected we
have four documents referring to the
community of Serbia municipalities not a
single one was implemented out of those
four documents the principles 21 or 22
principles are the most important that
were signed in
2015 signed by Issa Mustafa and me
a good part big part of those principles
is in proposed statute I cannot speak
any further about details because it's
been agreed with a big five not to come
up with
details and I'm not the one who's going
to breach the agreements or act
irresponsibly I said for the respective
document that it is a good basis a good
foundation for discussions and we are
ready to continue discussions on that
matter if you want me to be totally
frankly not be since I didn't plan for a
second in my introductory note to speak
about it or to mention Pristina side I
didn't do that because that's not my way
of uh transferring their
responsibility um I almost never do that
uh I'm afraid that we will not see uh
community of Serbian municipalities
anytime sooner because I know well all
the Balan tricks I've learned a lot to
recognize them I know who's doing what
and I'm afraid that only regarding that
issue we're going to be be in more
difficult position whether everybody in
Europe will be able to see that finally
I believe that quite a lot of people see
that quite well but let me tell you for
Ursula and everybody else of course the
substance is that we make more
concessions it's more logical because
they see differently on what we went
through in 999 2003 2004
2013 this is nothing unexpected it is
only that we somehow surprise all of a
sudden where those positions come from
but those are their positions you know
and those are much milder positions from
what I hear at the meetings so in my
opinion it's not bad to to hear that
sometimes just to have an idea what it
looks like and the positions that I hear
in our meetings from some member states
and from some EU
officials we can
only
wish to listen to positions like this
one which is much milder there are no
easy things for us there are no many
nice things for us in all that but we
have to say what our position is and we
must push forward our country needs to
develop at the same time by preserving
our state vital State and National
interest and thank you the next question
last question radio television of Serbia
tamaric for president fed lion firstly
you said that EU enlargement is on on
the top of the EU agenda and president
of the European Council Char Michelle
said month ago approximately that
2030 is the realistic year for the
countries of the western Balkans to
uh become EU members is it realistic in
your opinion or do you share the opinion
of some of your colleagues because EU
did not accept Western B countries
before or earlier having in mind the
situation that we have today in the old
continent Ukraine and now in the Middle
East you yourself said that there are so
many turbulences worldwide today and for
the president vuich though Madame fion
mentioned this already that you
discussed media laws what did she tell
you can you tell us some more details
about adopted media law thank
you
we spoke briefly about
um uh amendments to Media laws actually
I asked since I'm not fully familiar
with that I know that the government of
Serbia was in charge of that in Madam
babage first of all so I ask our
European friends and partners uh what
they thought about it what their opinion
was about it those are definitely
positive steps just like president of
the European commission has just said I
believe that we're going to continue
working on it I'll be fully open you
could hear this from Ula right now she
put this very mindly what our problems
are in accessing the EU and I'm grateful
to her for this soft approach of hers
and I'm not hiding this in front of our
people and it seems to me that they also
know that and I'm not hiding it in front
of everybody else our one fact is
our not full compliance with the
European foreign policy which is non
imposing sanctions to the Russian
Federation the other issue is our
relationship with Pristina where
probably will be subjective but it seems
to me not quite subjective on this
because um the bigger part of the blame
is not in
our on our side but of course we'll
continue implementing reforms in the
Democratic and judicial system of our
country there are many more things to be
done yet but if I may observe two
biggest obstacles for us in this moment
are Kosovo and meia and
um sanctions uh against the Russian
Federation anyway I'm grateful to for
I'm grateful for these nice messages
that Ula F lion uh conveyed today in
front of our people this growth is of
substantial importance for our country
and not only the growth plan but also
the investment plan
and even words in which president of
European commission said they expected
Serbia within the EU
membership uh it is up to us it's up to
our merits those are big and important
messages for our citizens and I want to
thank her once again I told her also
before this press conference we always
expect respect our guests but I am not
going to hide to hide from our people
what our problems are what the problems
that we are facing with our what is it
that we need to do
because from hiding something and making
things nicer than they are well we can
get nothing neither can they so anyway
we will continue on our European path we
will try to accelerate our European
integration we'll try to do many
things and I'm immensely immensely and
endlessly grateful to the European
taxpayers for the huge support they
provided for the Republic of Serbia in
previous period and particularly
grateful to president on the line
for not having any bothers of respecting
our country our citizens our people for
not finding it difficult to travel to
parts of our country that are far from
Belgrade and also to show her respect
for our citizens in our country she is
always welcome here in Serbia and what's
now up to us is
to pull up our sleeves and to try to do
everything that we can I mean everything
that is not directly against our
State national vital interest thank you
once again and sorry for speaking this
long thank you president thank you
Madame ferine de colleagues we hereby
finish today's press
conference